[Music]
have you ever wondered how video
monitoring systems are architected well
today you're in luck as we explore how
our cue list a video monitoring iot
company created their architecture in
the cloud i've invited pen their cloud
and security architect who will share
more with us today
hey ben welcome to the show how are you
and what do you do at our cue list hi
thank you priyanka my name is ben i am
the cloud and security architect
although oculus is still a startup vibe
um we
we operate under like kind of more of a
collaborative product team which allows
me to wear multiple hats i not only get
to kind of work on architecture and
security but also get to work on machine
learning look after multiple teams
and also get to experience more
hands-on with our more enterprise
customers wow that is all sorts of
different things from ml to security
that's that's a huge spectrum that you
work with
so we know at a very high level how
video and iot monitoring works but i'm
curious what our cue list exactly does
achilles takes all of the information
from a multitude of devices at the edge
and what we do is we have a small
appliance at the edge that kind of
captures all that information and then
processes it and then pushes it all the
way through into the cloud specifically
the google cloud
okay so
all right that that makes sense to me we
have some devices they're sending data
to the cloud and then there's some
processing happening with that data how
is it actually architected and i guess
before we even get to how is it actually
architected what is
video security as a service and then we
can dive into the architecture
sure video security as a service um is
kind of like a sas based product that's
obviously storing video typically um our
traditional competitors are vms's which
are video management solutions what they
do is they collect all this video
information make it easy for people to
find incidences or or people within
video across uh hundreds of cameras okay
then so what are the challenges in
building a system like this and i'm
actually really curious about why you
chose google cloud for this
sure uh we chose google cloud primarily
because of speed we we evaluated
multiple cloud providers at the time
because we wanted more of that
on-premise feel uh google won out
the other key key aspects of this as
well was access your product managers
and engineers directly that really
helped us as a startup to be able to get
get get more information faster and help
train our engineers up quicker as well
all right so time to get into the
architecture and the details and you've
given an indication that obviously
there's customer sites where you have
the iot devices that are sending the
data into google cloud and then there's
processing happening on there but i'm
curious about how the data makes it from
those iot devices into the cloud and
then what happens afterwards
sure so each of our customer sites
ultimately have a small appliance at the
edge that uh allows us to buffer the
information before it makes its way to
the cloud as we all know internet's
super reliable um so we are hardware
agnostic uh we can deploy on any bare
metal um we can also deploy inside of
vmware uh and then we have kubernetes at
the edge that allows us to deploy
multiple containers and different
systems as needed and ultimately shift
compute where it should be then also we
have a last mile connectivity um that's
really powerful um because that's
primarily the reason why we chose google
we're able to provide
almost near near zero latency as
ultimately it's just that last mile
piece
um so we're able to actually deliver
video sub seconds to anyone anywhere in
the world
awesome so
we got into we got into google cloud at
this point before the data gets into the
services running on gke
um you must have some load balancing
that's happening right
yeah so we actually have over 90 micro
services in gke today um so so we really
utilize gk it's super awesome um but
before obviously we hit the gk instance
we do use our load balancers we use both
l7 load balancers we do utilize some of
the more interesting features that you
have inside of the the http https load
balancing and endpoint connections uh
but we also use a lot of l4 uh for
instance with webrtc and then finally we
have iot core as well
um with iot core um we actually use that
for some of our metadata the metadata
flows up through
uh from some of those services at the
edge um and that feeds into pub sub um
which then also feeds into bigquery
we didn't talk much about the databases
that you're using i assume you're pretty
much the spread of both relational and
non-relational in this use case uh but
can you talk more about the databases
sure yeah we utilize all kinds of
databases uh some hyper-specific some
not so specific um probably one of our
biggest uses today is obviously using uh
we actually use cloud sql again with
that that lighter weight not not needing
to have to manage those instances um we
use both postgres and a bit of mysql
primarily postgres um we also use um
like you mentioned a couple of other
more exotic databases um we actually use
uh graph databases including a rango we
actually have an interesting nist based
permission graph model
which makes uh permissions way better
for horizontally scaling um
traditional methods don't work so well
uh single store we actually use that for
a high rate of ingestion we've tested
that to more than four
inserts per second
um
the postgas is mostly used for our
device configuration we have tens of
thousands of devices globally all of our
configurations stored in our cloud sql
postgres units uh and then bigquery
actually use for slow storage um so so
as we connect and have all these
different pieces of information coming
in through metadata we slow store that
inside a big query and obviously um
really powerful to be able to run jobs
across large data sets wow yeah that is
a lot and like i said like i imagine
it is a spread of all sorts of databases
um
they i want to go back a little bit and
dive into the video files themselves i i
think you mentioned briefly touched on
the fact that these video files are are
chunked and then you you put them into
into cloud storage so um can you talk a
little bit about that process because
yes this files are stored in cloud
storage but the way you do them sounds
really unique so i want to know more
about that
sure so video um is mostly stored today
inside of the
custom container format that we
ultimately use under the hood is
ultimately h.264 which is a very common
video format uh within video you have
keyframes uh and those keyframes are
chunked up uh depending on the camera
they may be at one second two seconds
four seconds um
and that's how we ultimately split that
data up
so we could be pushing
millions of files per month per device
depending on how that's created um we
actually recently built a new way of
aggregating that information so that we
didn't have to uh spend so much money on
our put requests and we use that in
combination with pub sub um all these
messages fly through pub sub and allow
us to get those into the information
into the databases to allow quicker
access okay okay well that makes a lot
of sense now deployment um what's your
ci cicd like how do you deploy these
micro services i heard 19 services so
i'm really curious how the deployment
works
sure yeah um we use a multitude of
different services deployment itself is
typically through spinnaker
um but our build process is actually
through the cloud build platform
we also heavily uh or heavy users of the
uh the container services that you have
as well for container management
deployment
so how do you actually monitor these
systems because there is a lot happening
here
sure yeah we use uh cloud operations uh
primarily as it's native to uh the
google platform that's a huge win for us
we also use new relic we also use
dynatrace for some services and then we
have our own stack with grafana and
prometheus as well depending on the
services that are being monitored
when it comes to dealing with a platform
like this security obviously is
extremely important because you're
pretty much doing video um and dealing
with sensitive data so specifically
um monitoring any open ports also it
could be a problem so how do you make
sure your architecture and components
are secure
sure um so that's really really
interesting so so we have all these
we we use
again multiple products to do that we
have our third-party penetration test
companies that we have we
we contract with to make sure that we
have that that covered from an external
true external perspective internally we
do use the utilize the api scanners we
also use the cloud security command
center that you have as well inside of
the product that does provide some
pretty good basic cis stuff which really
helps us understand which which ports
are open whether something is configured
we do have some other special source as
well um which i unfortunately cannot
talk about
thanks van i learned a lot with that
that entire architecture diagram but
what do future technical enhancements to
this architecture look like and
what is the next generation of video
analysis system i'm i'm pretty sure
you're imagining it um so i want to know
more about that
sure um from an architectural standpoint
and from more of uh like kind of
operation standpoint i think the next
things for us are actually implementing
istio
um maybe jaeger as well getting more
distributed tracing in
um from a machine learning perspective
we're kind of focusing on our machine
learning operations pipelines
allowing our users to potentially be
able to retrain on their own data and
getting much more granular in that kind
of aspect
and and then um
i think that's kind of the two key parts
thank you so much ben for spending some
time with me today and sharing about the
video monitoring systems
thank you priyanka it's been awesome
i don't know about you but i learned a
lot today how iot devices send data how
video monitoring is done and how all the
data is used for business insights and
machine learning my mind is absolutely
blown but the cool part is it all begins
with a plan and there's always a really
cool architecture to uncover i've
included some resources for you to check
out in the description below and i'll
see you next time
you